[Music]
okay so the batman has one of my
favorite endings to a comic book movie
ever not only does it bring the
character's arc bold circle from being a
figure that represents vengeance but it
also symbolizes the dedication that
bruce wayne has to gotham just before
the release of the movie we did a video
breaking down the ending of the dark
knight which is also one of the best
endings to a film that i can think of
it's kind of wild to me that both that
and the batman culminate with bruce
riding off on a motorbike and in many
ways they both symbolize the same things
about the character but for different
reasons whereas the dark knight had
bruce sacrificing the icon that batman
was in order to protect good the batman
has bruce sacrificing his happiness to
protect his city it really works on a
number of levels and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
exactly why we love it so much and if
you agree then we'd massively appreciate
the thumbs up also make sure you
subscribe for videos like this every day
and don't forget to turn on
notifications to stay up to date with
the channel that's about bringing just
dice like mr freeze without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the video
[Music]
now in order to talk about the ending we
have to go back to the first scene of
the film in which we're introduced to
batman coming from the shadows in the
form of a figure known as vengeance he
breaks out some hand-to-hand combat to
take out an entire group of thugs after
this shocking fight we see that victim
carrying on the ground terrified of the
figure that's just saved his life
please don't hurt me
like a demon from the shadows batman has
mercilessly come forth and taking out a
gang of bad bad boys with affleck of his
wrist without the bed dear me
it was stuck with the crap puns no more
i promise now this is important because
it sets him up as someone who
intimidates everyone in the city both
bad and good after his signal shines in
the sky he's called to a crime scene
which is where he meets the first victim
of the riddler throughout the movie we
watch as he carries out a rampage on the
corrupting gotham and in many ways
riddler is batman on steroids becoming
the bane of his life think we got away
with that one now the villain is just an
extreme version of batman and the pair
mirror each other in many ways after
capturing him riddler even believes that
they're so aligned that he'll want to
partner with him and this ideology flows
to his followers too upon beating down a
third they announced their vengeance
showing how batman's inspiration has
caused more harm than good now this is
something that bruce himself states at
the start of the movie when talking
about the effect that he's had i wish i
could say i'm making a difference
[Music]
murder robberies assault
two years later they're all up it's at
this point that he realizes that he's
not the hero that gotham needs or
deserves and that he has to become
better if things are gonna improve at
this point bruce goes through a literal
baptism in order to stop a group of
helpless souls from getting electrocuted
upon rising out of the water he reaches
out to bel real who's very much a symbol
of real change in the city bit on the
nose there but initially she's hesitant
to go with him however the person that
steps forward first is the mae's son who
very much symbolizes bruce as a child
much like him his father was killed and
this tragedy will clearly affect him for
a long time in saving him first matt
reeve showcases that bruce has managed
to pull not only the kid but also
himself out of the darkness into
something brighter i think reeves is an
absolutely brilliant director and
throughout this scene he very much
paints out batman as a beacon through
the use of a player which he carries
through the darkness batman leads them
out and it's over the top of this that
we get the narration that juxtaposes his
comments from earlier in the movie that
very much feel like a moment of
self-reflection
i'm starting to see now
i have had an effect here
[Music]
but not the one i intended
i have to become more
people need hope
to know someone's out there for them
we watch as he carries a young girl to
be rescued and she is used to reflect
the change in the public's perception of
batman unlike the man at the train
station she grabs onto his arm and
almost refuses to let go showing how
he's now become a symbol of hope now
after the joker and relatives we get
bruce and selena having their final
potting words after looking over her
mother's grave she packs up her cat and
decides to head to bloodhaven batman
clearly wants her to stay though
where will he go
why
you asking me to stay
she very much predicts what's gonna
happen to gotham and why it's best to
get out whilst the both of them still
can't with carmine gone it's only gonna
get worse for you there's gonna be a
power grab
it'll be bloody
i know
at this point she offers him another
life instead of the one that she thinks
is gonna end up killing him it's gonna
kill you eventually you know that
bruce almost seems like he's tempted by
it but the signal burns through the sky
which takes his attention away from her
she then utters the line that he's
spoken for which pulls directly from the
ending of zero year in the batman comics
from here together the pair ride through
a cemetery before they park up at the
fork in the road selena then rides off
to bloodhaven whilst bruce stays behind
now i don't think it's going to be a
surprise to anyone to know that this
film is based on detective noir stories
and selena herself very much represents
the femme fatale archetype this is often
described as being someone who's
seductive that loses the protagonist
either into a trap or they offer
something that tempts them away from
their main goal catwoman has pretty much
always been one in every form of media
and the one in the dark knight rises of
course led bruce to face up against bane
where he was badly beaten anne
hathaway's version also said that he'd
given everything he could and she wanted
to flee gotham with him before the nuke
went off which he also turned down
similar to that selena here is very much
tempting bruce with another life that
goes beyond the one he subjected himself
to bruce has very much dedicated himself
to this mission at the expense of
everything else and she offers him a
form of happiness that will lead him out
of the inevitable path of
self-destruction that he's now on
however he turns her down and i love the
way that he looks at her in the mirror
as she rides off down the road she very
much represents someone free from the
trappings that he finds himself in and
it's almost like he has second thoughts
as he watches her right off into the
smoke however he quickly brushes this
idea to the side and turns his eyes back
to the road to focus on his mission once
more i get lots of flashes to things
like the ending of memento where it
feels very tragic and bittersweet the
mission has become the only thing that
bruce really lives for at this point and
he's willing to sacrifice any chance at
happiness in order to continue being
batman ever since his parents murder
bruce has dedicated his entire life to
making sure that nothing like that ever
happens to anyone else he's trained his
body and mind to perfection so that he's
pretty much a weapon ready to tackle any
threat that may be posed to him mentally
or physically because of this he's now
very much at a point in his life where
this is all he has and in making his
life all about one thing there's
absolutely no balance bruce is a
completely broken man but he also
represents the sacrifice that comes if
one wants to be a hero batman is a
symbol of hope across the city and if he
was to take this away it could end up
causing more damage especially as gotham
is now at breaking point most of
downtown is flooded and the inevitable
power vacuum that will appear means that
there's gonna have to be someone in the
city who can stand up to the people that
will now be buying for control this is
very much what batman is and bruce
realizes that i think in these final
moments he very much takes a glance at
selena and you kind of get the feeling
he's almost imagining the happier life
he could have with her for a brief
second before she disappears instead of
turning around and going with her though
he keeps his eyes to the road rides into
the future and back to his city which
he's going to protect no matter what
it's a brilliant ending that very much
surmises what it means to be batman and
also the cost that comes with it like
something ripped out of the film
chinatown or a 70s classic it paints out
the sad cost that comes with trying to
be a force for good and how one must
lose the things they care about in order
to pursue goals like this it's masterful
storytelling done simply through the
eyes of pattinson who betrays all the
stoic emotion longing that he feels in
this glance i know there's an argument
but white eyes being used on the cowl
but i think it would rob us in moments
like this we see the wonder that exists
in him and then the focus as he turns
his eyes back at the road and takes
himself out of the fantasy overall it's
an incredible way to end the movie and
it's the perfect way to close out this
first chapter going forward though i'd
love to see this scene repeated as we
close our patents in zork and perhaps
one day we'll get this bike ride where
he decides to go with selena instead of
staying behind however i doubt it and
that's because that's what batman
represents the self-sacrifice that it
takes to be a symbol of hope and overall
it feels like the perfect ending
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know we are in a competition right
now and giving away three copies of
spider-man no way home on the 15th of
may and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the ending we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out writing of all
the easter eggs in the film which will
be linked on screen right now it's one
of the best videos on the channel we're
super proud of it so definitely go check
it out right after this without the way
thanks for sending through the video
i've been poor let's see in the next one
take care peace